here are 60 Hogwarts Legacy details you
may have missed from the recent gameplay
showcase we'll start off our list in the
Hufflepuff dorm room and this room is
full of tiny little details that long
time fans are going to absolutely love
starting with the fact that it appears
we have a quaffle sitting on top of the
Wardrobe here even though quidditch is
not playable in Hogwarts Legacy it is
still expected to be part of the world
and perhaps we'll even be able to see
other characters playing the sport also
in the dorm room it seems that pets are
confirmed we see an owl here however the
Character Creator was also revealed in
full as part of this gameplay showcase
and we did not see an area there to
choose an owl cat or toad Diagon Alley
has yet to be confirmed and it seems our
character will be starting their
Hogwarts journey and perhaps an
unconventional manner that won't include
a trip to the iconic location as it did
with Harry perhaps this will actually be
selected later in the game or maybe even
purchased in hogsmead instead now
throughout this entire gameplay showcase
you're going to notice a number of these
little white indicate above various
items and anytime you see that it means
that this item can be interacted with
and one that I will call out here is
this interactable teacup just next to
the bed now on the bedside table here
you may immediately look and see oh this
must be chocolate frogs and then birdie
bought every flavor beans but notice
that the design is just slightly
different than what we're used to what's
interesting about this is that birdie
bought every flavor beans hadn't been
yet invented by 1890 of course when the
game takes place as far as chocolate
frog cards go the packaging is different
here however this would actually be
right in line with the Canon and talk
about really getting in the Weeds on all
the details here because this one
actually comes to us through the
Fantastic Beasts films and it's a single
shot of the cover of a daily profit
article and this is actually from a 1926
copy of the paper which talks about a
new chocolate frog packaging being
launched now a lot of people in the
fandom will say that the chocolate frog
cards were not included up until this
point and they cite this article as a
source for that now it will be
interesting to see if these chocolate
frogs contain wizard cards or not it's
worth noting that we have not yet seen
anything at all to indicate that wizard
cards will be collectible in this game
and even if they are collectible there
would be a number of wizards that we
know about from the main series who
wouldn't be included at all because it
simply hadn't taken place yet now we
also see that there is a flu flame right
here inside the common room and we also
learned that you don't have to do
anything special to unlock these you
simply walk by and discover them in the
world and then they'll instantly be
unlocked now what isn't yet clear is if
we'll be able to sneak into other common
rooms and if we do can we discover their
flu flames and then use that as a way to
get inside without having to go through
the traditional measure of either a
password for the case of Gryffindor and
Slytherin answering the riddle for
Ravenclaw or tapping the wall for
Hufflepuff now when they actually leave
the Hufflepuff common room we get
another brief tantalizing tease of the
Hogwarts kitchens that's right long time
fans of the series will know that just
behind this portrait of the fruit are
the Hogwarts kitchens which we have
actually already seen very briefly but
we have seen a glimpse inside the
kitchens here of course we know that you
get in here by tickling the pear I love
seeing that little tease from the devs
as we were going through this gameplay
showcase now as we start going up the
stairs you'll notice everyone's favorite
Poltergeist sliding down the banister
here very quickly I actually missed this
one completely the first time and it
wasn't until I watched it again that I
caught peeps sliding by right there now
once we reached the top of the staircase
we see an interesting prompt over here
on the left side very briefly we see the
words Roll appear on screen now what do
you think is meant by roll there is that
going to be the start of a puzzle let me
know down in the comments below we also
got our first look at some of the menus
in Hogwarts Legacy and I absolutely love
the menu here that features the Hogwarts
Legacy Field Guide which we also learned
in this gameplay showcase is given to us
by the ministry of magic as far as the
story goes it's pretty interesting to
note that the ministry of magic is
taking notice of our character which
makes me even more curious to see what
happens at the beginning of that game to
reveal our character's ancient magic
assumably for the first time now would
we get a look at this menu you'll notice
that the talent section is grayed out
here and you'll also see the text which
reads progress through the main story to
unlock so this indicates to us that the
talents will not be unlocked right away
and it's something you'll have to play
through the game a little bit before you
open this up now you'll also notice that
they choose to separate out quests and
challenges which as a completionist has
me really excited I want to do
absolutely everything that there is to
see and do in this game so to be able to
track them easily through these two
menus will be very nice now here in this
next area you'll notice a couple of
crests that we have seen before in other
areas of Hogwarts Legacy it remains to
be seen if these are just kind of here
for decoration or if they're actually
going to be connected to Something in
the story now earlier we talked about
that little white indicator indicating
that something can be interacted with
here we see a slightly different
gameplay effect with this sort of
shining silhouette around this entire
statue here which to me indicates that
it is something more than just an
interactable object perhaps there's a
secret entrance here or something else
to be unlocked now in this shot here
just ever so briefly near the top of the
screen we will see this spinning ball
that's what a lot of people are
referring to it as I actually think it
is called an armillary sphere and these
were devices used in the 17th and 18th
century to show the difference between
the theory of a central Earth and the
theory of a central Sun you'll notice
here that we have a couple of stone
dragons and then what I believe is a
zuwu here I know some people say zawu
but I heard an interview with JK Rowling
and she said Zoo so that's how I'm going
to pronounce it moving forward a little
bit and ever so briefly on the right
side here we'll see a statue of a
werewolf now up next one of my favorite
Parts in the gameplay showcase is we get
a little preview of what I think is a
puzzle for the game in this next area we
have four braziers each with a symbol on
the front now three of these braziers
are unlit however the last one that we
get to on the left here you will see is
already lit so I can't wait to find out
what exactly is going to happen once we
light all the operations here now a lot
of times to make a game in a world just
feel alive it's all of the little
details so right here at this section of
the Showcase I love that we see students
flying overhead on brooms we already
know flying is in the game we're gonna
be able to fly ourselves including these
various challenges that we're going to
be able to do but to see that this is a
living breathing world I mean I don't
know if that was scripted or if every
time we're outside in Hogwarts we're
just going to notice random students
kind of flying around that's what I hope
it is because it is such a nice touch
now also in this little scene right here
there was a lot happening at this part
guys game director Alan 2 dropped what I
think is one of the biggest bits of news
from this entire showcase and it's when
he said everything you see is a place
that you can visit so all of this that
we see here outside of Hogwarts is a
place that we're going to be able to go
to and check out of course we already
know about hogsmead what else is lying
out there in the ground surrounding
Hogwarts now also in this same little
section right here we have this rain
cloud just I don't know raining randomly
so maybe the start of another puzzle now
in terms of making that world feel alive
this living and breathing world we
talked about the people on broomsticks
already but how about this Ravenclaw
student right here just carrying what I
don't know a giant tablet a giant book
along with this quill and seeing this
makes me wonder are we going to have
NPCs with various routines that they
follow throughout the game perhaps even
story elements now this is something
that games have been doing for a long
time Legend of Zelda started doing it I
mean I remember it all the way back in
Ocarina of Time in Majora's Mask it was
one of the most jaw-dropping pieces of
that game is when you had these
characters with these little routines
that you could only access certain parts
of a quest if it was at a specific time
of day at a specific moment within their
routine now there's another one here
we're going to talk about toward the end
of the video that I'll mention as well
and of course I don't expect that every
single NPC we meet is going to have just
this routine of course there's going to
be some Randomness to it but I'm hopeful
that there are at least a few characters
roaming about the world who have special
time-based quests now as they're looking
out here over the terrain surrounding
Hogwarts you'll also make out the
greenhouse just here on the right side
then moments later we actually get a
look at what this looks like from in
inside the castle here so this here the
entrance to the greenhouse just
absolutely gorgeous and the color scheme
the color palette right here of course
matches that exact same green that we
saw from the outside now just when they
make their way into this next area we
see an incredible tapestry featuring a
hybridian black dragon now I don't know
about you guys but at this point I think
they're trying to tell us this dragon is
somewhat significant we have seen the
hybridian black dragon in so many
different places from the original
trailer of the game we even see a
hybridian black dragon skeleton in
Professor heckett's defense against the
dark arts classroom we've also seen a
skeleton of it outside here we've seen
it in screenshots I mean we have seen
this Dragon so many times now so the
fact that we see it yet again here on
this tapestry tells me that this could
be a significant piece to the puzzle in
Hogwarts Legacy now this next scene is
one of my favorite parts of the entire
trailer because I gotta be honest with
you guys I am terrible with directions
seriously absolutely terrible I know
some people don't like the waypoints in
games and feel that it kind of breaks
the immersion but honestly I need that
stuff guys my wife has always given me a
hard time about this because even in
real life I mean I just constantly
terrible sense of direction so this area
I found particularly interesting because
one of the developers Boston Madsen
called this area The Hub of the school
Grand Central Station is another phrase
she used for it and what I thought was
so interesting is that she talked about
how they designed this to where people
will not get lost and the primary way
they're doing that is through the use of
color to help out with directions we
already talked about the greenhouse and
that certain color palette but the way
she described this here essentially
after you make your way through here a
few times you should start to get to
sort of a natural feel for where things
are supposed to be so I gotta tell you
me more than any other I'm gonna be the
one to put this to test we'll see if I
can actually find my way around the
school we should also point out that
Community manager Chandler Woods said
they still get lost in the castle all
the time now in this Hub area we also
see a number of Latin phrases written
here now one of these in particular will
be very familiar to Harry Potter fans
and it's this one here which means never
tickle a sleeping Dragon then we have
this one here and you guys notice I'm
not even going to try and pronounce
these but this one means Perpetual
learning this one by teaching we learn
another here let knowledge be power and
then the last one here through
difficulties to honors now I know
earlier we talked about that little
white dot which indicates an interaction
and I haven't been calling out
everything but I want to call out this
one in particular because I've seen a
lot of people requesting sitting can we
sit in this game which I personally find
kind of a strange request but hey some
people may just want to sit down relax
for a bit just listen to the ambience
listen to the music listen to the
chatter in Hogwarts Legacy and so this
one here actually makes me think we
might be able to sit down because ever
so briefly we see it right there and
notice it's not up on the fountain it's
actually down where the bench is of
course it could be something involving
the fountain but hopefully for all those
people who want to be able to sit maybe
this will actually let you do it now
speaking of that Fountain we also see a
number of magical creatures here
starting with the unicorn and yet
another werewolf it appears that the
Goblins are actually positioned here and
then we also have some myrrh people
going around the edges it's also
interesting to note that of the four
creatures here only the Goblins have
been officially confirmed to be in
Hogwarts Legacy so it'll be interesting
to see whether unicorns werewolves or
mer people make an appearance as well
now in this next shot here we get a
first look at what quest givers will
look like in Hogwarts Legacy as
indicated by this little Golden Ring
around them now here in this shot we get
a look at the Field Guide page you'll
notice a couple of these in the trailer
I'm not going to call out every one of
them now this next symbol right here is
a symbol that we have seen a number of
times now it appears to be a triangle a
circle and then a question mark in the
center you'll see one here on the right
if we were to go up the stairs and then
also one here on the right at the bottom
of the stairs and then to the right of
that we see a door that could possibly
be an entrance to the ancient runes
classroom now if you're thinking you've
seen something very similar before
you're right in the developer behind the
scenes video we see what I think is the
other side of this door the inside of
the ancient runes classroom now what's
also interesting about this is each of
these magical creatures indicate a
number we have the Demi guys here for
zero unicorn for one grab horn for two
Rune Spore for three swooper for four
quintaped for five salamander for six an
unknown creature for seven acromantula
for eight and a Hydra for nine now
another interesting detail about this
gameplay showcase is that it seems like
every student that we interact or do
battle with in this gameplay showcase
has an exact name including one Hector
Weasley wait what okay guys if you
missed this one I forgive you so our boy
James AKA expecto go recently posted his
behind the scenes video from his time at
Avalanche and there's a brief moment
here where you can see that he's having
a meeting with the devs while there is
the game playing in the background and
it honestly blows me away that people
found this I didn't even think to try
and zoom in on the TV screen here but if
you zoom in it seems like there is a
moment where the player character is
doing battle with a wizard by the name
of Hector Weasley now once we we
actually start interacting and talking
with the students an interesting detail
is dropped that's right she mentions
former headmistress upraxia mole now
I've told the story a number of times on
the channel eupraxia mole is the one who
had an incredible event with peeves the
Poltergeist seriously it's hilarious
story guys about the caretaker at the
time and how he thought he could get rid
of peeps yeah didn't work out so well
and you praxia mole headmistress at the
time had to solve everything and come to
a deal with peeps now just a couple of
lines later she also mentions Professor
black who is highly likely to be Phineas
black and the fact that mole was a
former headmistress makes it even more
likely that Phineas black is our
Headmaster during our time in Hogwarts
Legacy alright yet another detail about
the world just feeling alive check out
this kid in the background here if
you're wondering what is going on with
him here it is most likely a pepper up
potion so this is a potion that Wizards
and witches used for the common cold one
of the unfortunate side effects though
is that it would cause steam to emit
from the drinker's ears for hours after
taking the post ocean so don't worry I
think he's gonna be all right now this
next spot here where our character is
getting ready to walk into this door one
of the most interesting things of this
entire showcase happens because from
what I can find it's the only time we
see this notice right down here on the
left side by the minimap we get a brief
pop-up with a named location and it
appears that this happens when the
character is going into this new area
now I looked throughout the whole
gameplay showcase and did not find
anywhere else where this happens even
when our character goes inside and
outside of areas so I'm not sure if
something specific triggered here maybe
this is the first time they discovered
it or maybe there's something else going
on and I'm just kind of misreading the
situation but it's also interesting to
note the name which is Hall of herodiana
hero Diana yeah I look for references
guys couldn't find anything to Harry
Potter so they must be pulling from
something else here with this one any
thoughts you have I'd love to hear them
in the comments below about what this
could be a reference to now we'd seen a
brief shot of a howler before in another
Hogwarts Legacy trailer but we see one
over here on the left side and the
students are just kind of cowering
before this one now we know there are
going to be plenty of Secrets hidden
throughout Hogwarts Legacy so check out
this one right here a chest just
blending in perfectly here in the back
corner that brown along with the brown
of the wall makes that one so hard to
notice I also love just outside the
defense against the dark arts classroom
and all throughout the classroom we have
dark detectors now what's interesting
about dark detectors is it's not just
one thing there are several different
devices which actually qualify as dark
detectors we have the faux glass which
we know about thanks to Barty Crouch Jr
pretending to be mad Eye Moody and
Harry's fourth year another one called a
probity probe secrecy sensors
sneakoscopes and then the one we see
here a trace tracking dark detector now
these were actually featured somewhat
prominently in the Harry Potter Mobile
Game Wizards unite now this classroom is
actually full of so many details you
guys it would take me forever to go
through all of them I'm just going to
highlight a couple here starting with
the fact that this door actually appears
like it is interactable so perhaps at
some point we'll actually be able to go
into Professor heckett's private study
here we also see a drawing of a thestral
on the wall here a statue here that is
very similar similar to the ones that we
found in the Slytherin common room and
then the one that I just cannot figure
out what this is I mean it looks like a
house elf when you're right here which
creepy but then we move forward just a
bit and this one here is sitting up a
little bit higher on the Shelf we kind
of see it from a different angle and
this one almost looks like a beaked mask
instead of a household really hoping
it's a big mask here now we also get a
portrait here of Gwendolyn the weird who
was a witch in The 14th Century she was
captured no less than 47 times in
various disguises because she actually
enjoyed being burned at the stake she
would use a flame freezing charm which
would give a pleasant tickling sensation
alright this next one I really need your
help again guys what is this head I mean
that's all I can think it looks like a
giant head I know it's obviously not
this but the first thing I thought of
was the big head on Fred and George's
shop I have no idea what this one could
be now earlier we talked about the
possibility of students having various
routines that they carry throughout the
day notice here that we have another
student who appears to be carrying
something can't quite make out what it
is maybe it's an okay that's been
wrapped up in a package here we have yet
another tool to hopefully help us find
our way around the castle with a compass
on the floor could possibly use this to
help find a certain location and then we
also have the GPS map here in the bottom
left of your screen now just as our
character makes their way through here
we get a brief Glimpse at a locked door
which reads level one lock so is this
gonna be alohomora or is there going to
be something else that we have to learn
to get through here the fact that it's
level one could indicate that there are
going to be various upgrades we need to
apply on spells to make them stronger
now we talked about peeves earlier we
saw him briefly we get another look at
him here a little bit longer than the
first one and of course he's doing what
he does best just messing with students
making their lives miserable now my
biggest question here about peeves is
are these scripted events or is it just
completely random because I am just
loving the idea of peeves just having
his own kind of AI where he roams about
the castle at will and you never know
when you're gonna run into him I think
that would be great now as we make our
way into the crossed wands dueling Club
if you look closely over here on the
right you'll know notice the little
shine of yet another locked door now
there's been a lot of talk about
companions lately I actually think
they're going to be changing that
terminology to relationship instead and
part of my reasoning for that is this
moment right here notice after we talk
with Luke and Brad will be here we get
the pop-up on the top right corner of
the screen which says complete side
slash relationship Quest now speaking of
the companions two of the confirmed
companions are natsionai and Sebastian
sallow now we see them here in the cross
once dueling club and have a moment
where we could actually choose to have
one of them as our partner in the duel
or no one at all now because of the way
this gameplay showcase was set up there
was a lot of talking over the actual
gameplay so we didn't get to hear a lot
of what was going on now I actually
interviewed expecto go about his time at
Avalanche one of his favorite Parts is
the sound the ambient noise the sounds
of conversation going on happening in
Hogwarts as you're walking around
unfortunately this did not come through
well on the stream however around the 30
minute Mark there is a brief moment
while Chandler Wood Community manager is
talking that if you listen very
carefully you can actually hear one of
these conversations stations happening
between Sebastian and Nancy a mini tour
of Hogwarts and again but a fraction of
uh this enormous Castle
but we're closing it out here in the
Clock Tower so another recognizable
location but this is where shout out to
Eugene the magical over on Twitter for
that one by the way now we also got our
most extensive look yet at spells and
combat in Hogwarts Legacy I'm actually
gonna have a whole separate video
breaking combat down but one thing that
you very easily could have missed here
about the controls is that there is a
brief moment where they show us that R3
is going to be the button that you use
to lock on to characters in the game and
then you can kind of flick left and
right using R3 to cycle between
different enemies there are also
multiple spell types in the game that
they had to break into different
categories three of the categories
mentioned were damage force and control
now we also got a look at some Shields
that enemies are gonna have during the
game these are also color coded and it
requires a spell of that same color so
basically the spell that falls in that
category to break them so my personal
guess is that damage is going to be the
red purple is likely to be the four
spells like Akio and pulso and then
yellow I'm guessing is going to be the
control spells like levioso and again I
know it's lettyosa but guys when
guardium Leviosa and levioso different
spell now they only briefly teased this
little symbol right here which if you've
been following the game for any amount
of time you know is the ancient magic
symbol they're still kind of being koi
being secretive on what exactly that's
going to trigger I think we've already
seen some of what it triggers in the
other trailers but it seems that we
actually build this meter up by
performing combos we can see the combo
meter building up at various points in
this gameplay showcase game director
Alan 2 also called some of the Spells
essential spells and said they wanted
these on the controller at all times one
of these is going to be protego which is
triggered by pressing the triangle
button if you're a PlayStation user why
for Xbox and for PC who the heck knows
this point now if you didn't watch this
all the way to the end there was a very
quick trailer they played which showed a
couple of new things including a
different owl than what we saw at the
very beginning of of this which to me
seems to confirm that this is a
changeable pet something that we the
player can choose again the question is
when and how we also talked earlier
about all the names for the students in
Hogwarts it also seems like our enemies
are going to have titles as well but not
specific names here we just see
ashwinder Scout and ashwinder Ranger now
the ashwinder is a magical creature from
the Harry Potter series that is a thin
pale gray snake with glowing red eyes
and these creatures would actually be
formed from the remains of a magical
fire that was essentially allowed to
burn unchecked this little trailer at
the end also showed us a few more
details about the minimap including the
fact that enemies will show up as red
arrows and also for some reason the room
of requirement does not show up on the
mini-map now one thing you'll notice I
did not talk about much in this video is
the Hogwarts Legacy character creator
that's because I already have a full
video dedicated to the breakdown of that
which you can check out on the right
side of your screen now as always thank
you all so much for watching I'll talk
to you again soon